welcome who went hunting demons leg  brothers Sam and Dean Winchester Jared  Padalecki and Jensen Ackles  [Applause]  oh yeah we go that way yeah here we go  here we go  all right we got so much to talk about  there are so many people that are  excited to see you here tonight  let me begin by you guys have such great  on-air chemistry and I think it's  because you are you're terrific actors  but your friends in real life you guys  have been good friends for a long time  well as long as the show's been around  okay yeah well okay  Jensen you said once that you would take  a bullet for Jared did you mean that let  me clarify a nerf bullet under was being  handed yeah you would pass it on to him  okay okay  you